There are three main types of mobile
ads that can be used in a game.
Banner ads, interstitial ads,
and offer walls.
The most commonly used ads are banner
ads, which are banners, at the top or
bottom of the screen.
These are simple to place in your game
without obscuring the whole screen.
And you can size them to
fit different devices.
>> Another type of ad is interstitial
ads which take up the whole screen and
the user has to manually close them.
They auto-fit the screen or
whatever device you're on.
And so you want to put them at
natural pauses in the game.
Because these ads take up more space,
and more of a player's attention than
banner ads, users are much
more likely to click on them.
And this makes these ads a little
more profitable than banner ads.
>> They take a lot of the screen
like interstitial ads,
but also include videos to watch.
And after you watch them, you can get
game power ups or in-game currency.
These are all good ways of
integrating ads into your game.
But it's important not
to have too many ads
because they may start
to seem like spam.
So place your adds at points where
it seems natural to pause and
keep your game experience a priority.